Speaker 1: I unfortunately have to do this
segment. There are dangerously delusional
people in my audience. And one of the
sorts of segments that brings it out
is when I report facts, not giving my opinion, I
give plenty of opinions on this show. I'll say,
listen, I'm against the death penalty. That's
my opinion. Let me tell you why. And people will
write in and they'll say, oh, well, you know, I
agree with you or I disagree or whatever, but we
know we're talking about opinion. Last week, I
reported to you that the rate of inflation was
down. I didn't say that we have deflation. That's
different. I said the rate of inflation is down.
A healthy economy expects a little bit of
inflation. I've explained why the rate of
inflation is down. It wasn't my opinion. These are
the numbers, and the numbers have been measured
more or less the same way for decades. And I want
to give you some examples of the responses I saw,
the comments I saw on YouTube, and you will very
quickly see that we have a tragedy of critical
thinking, really lack of critical thinking in
this country. Jeff responded, quoting me, used
car prices have gone down low. Well, obviously
someone isn't in the used car market. Remember,
this isn't me driving around looking at used car
prices. We have monthly data on this issue. Folks
like Jeff, when the data said used car prices are
up. Agreed with it because it was what they wanted
to tell is a story because Joe Biden's president
and he's driving up the prices of used cars even
though it started under Donald Trump during
the pandemic. And now it's, oh, you're not in
the used car market, so you don't actually
know what's going on with used car prices.
This is, in my opinion. This is the data. If you
went to one used car lot and saw an expensive used
car, that doesn't mean anything about what's going
on nationally. Okay. Next example from Tulsa. Have
you checked the math David Pakman. I bet if you
check it, you will find that it's off a lot.
I don't know what that means. I am
reporting to you the inflation data.
We have done stories on what goes into the
inflation number. I'm not doing the math, but it's
not math in the sense you think it is. This is the
same inflation data that when inflation was high,
folks like this pointed to and said, look, here
are the numbers. Look at how high inflation is.
Not an inflation is coming down. They're like,
oh, no, the math is all wrong. Really. What do
you know about the math? I'm curious. Mr. Talks
responded low. Well, I call B.S. I don't see
prices dropping and eggs are sky high. Eggs aren't
cheap. So. Nope. Now, my personal experience is
also that eggs are expensive right now. That's
true. You know, I buy my pasture raised,
cage free, liberal hipster eggs, and they're
expensive. They absolutely are expensive. But
I understand that my experience of buying eggs is
anecdotal and it doesn't tell me what's going on
with inflation numbers nationally. But Mr. Talk
saw expensive eggs, so the numbers must be fake.
Brian wrote in Inflation is down where nothing
has gone down in price. Where I live, I miss
the old David Pakman who didn't always simper
for the establishment. You might as well work
for CNN or MSNBC. You know, these comments are
fascinating. When I report that gas prices are up
during Joe Biden's presidency, people like Brian
go, It's Biden's fault. It's terrible what's going
on. No questioning of the data. When I report that
inflation is down based on the same sources, Brian
doesn't like the content. So it must be that I'm
simple for the establishment. I report data data
that has been measured the same way for decades
unemployment, stock market, inflation. These
aren't opinions, folks, Tzipi wrote in. I'm not
seeing it. Prices are high in Philadelphia again.
You don't understand the difference between
anecdotes and data. How many times do I have
to explain this? A newman with a total.
What about ism? Where is the coverage on
the classified documents, David? Well, I'll tell
you where it isn't in my segment about inflation.
The coverage of the classified documents is in
the segment about classified documents. Classic.
What about ism? And then lastly, Robert says
he's this is a different approach. This is the
God fearing approach. Your narrative and lies are
catching up to you. God's watching you, Parkman.
Presented completely without comment. This
is really scary because we are here in a
country where the average person lacks a
basic degree of ability to think through
a problem. Wow. The report, after inflation
being really high is that inflation is lower.
I saw that eggs were expensive. Is that
a logical way to contradict a report? No,
it's not. But of course, that's not the
type of thinking that we frequently see.